uovo veri giochi
ho deciso di iniziare questa
conversazione questa chiacchierata con
voi
scrivendo il mio indirizzo twitter
perché la chiacchierata è tra persone
che sono vicine come in questo caso è
tra persone che sono da altre parti del
mondo ma che hanno voglia di conversare
con noi
io quando ero piccolo non vedevo droni
volare in cielo non c'erano bambini che
programmavano videogames e questo gesto
col dito lo facevo al limite per
metterlo nel barattolo della nutella per
mangiare qualcosa
sono nato nel 1975 da allora il mondo è
cambiato e ricambiato e probabilmente
nei prossimi anni cambierà ancora tante
tantissime volte nel 1975 c'era il mito
del posto fisso il posto fisso in banca
tutti si sposavano il matrimonio era la
cosa più normale del mondo e si viveva
in un mondo che era fatto di certezze
quelle certezze oggi non ce ne abbiamo
più le banche hanno iniziato e
continuano a licenziare
io ho scoperto sulla mia pelle che il
matrimonio non era per tutti anche se
prima o poi patrick ce la facciamo
e ho scoperto che i posti fissi di colpo
sparivano uno dopo l'altro un istante
dopo l'altro
e mentre alcuni di noi imparavano a
correre altri provavano a muovere i
primi passi c'è stata una sorta di
inversione a u contromano in autostrada
tutto è cambiato il nostro mondo è
cambiato ci siamo trovati
improvvisamente disorientati nel 1998
avevo 23 anni ci si commetteva alla rete
che proprio ieri ha compiuto 30 anni in
italia ci si connetteva con questi modem
un po vecchi impolverati qualcuno se lo
ricorderà quel
ora è insopportabile una cosa
stranissima io nella mia camera vivevo
ancora con i miei genitori ci metteva un
cuscino sopra la sera per riuscire a
connettermi senza svegliare tutta la
casa nel 1998 non sapevo quale sarebbe
stata la mia vita ma avevo imparato
subito una cosa che devi continuare ad
ascoltare e osservare ea imparare da
quello che stai ascoltando e osservando
ho iniziato nel 1998 la mia vita
digitale senza probabilmente ancora
sapere che sarebbe stata una vita
digitale vicino a piazza sant'agostino a
milano in una modesto ufficio insieme a
un gruppo di persone straordinarie
all'avanguardia ho realizzato il primo
magazine italiano totalmente su cd rom
quando internet era ancora poco diffuso
c'era un cd rom dentro cui noi avevamo
messo interi mondi tantissimi video
interviste mi ricordo quando abbiamo
realizzato uno speciale a sanremo non
dormivo note giorno per riuscire a
realizzare poi montare quelle interviste
ho trovate un'immagine un po vecchia si
chiamava fantastica cd rom ed era una
sorta di gigantesco portale online tutto
appunto su questo cd che potevi
guardarti a casa era talmente avanti che
per funzionare questo cd rom aveva
bisogno di un pentium 386 però nelle
case degli italiani all'epoca c'erano al
massimo i pentium 286 e così dal
fallimento di quella esperienza
otto mesi dopo questo straordinario
prodotto all'avanguardia ha smesso di
esistere
ecco da quel momento ho imparato la
prima regola che vorrei condividere con
voi questo pomeriggio che è una regola
per me fondamentale nella mia vita e nel
digitale la regola e b.time lei sì al
posto giusto nel momento giusto a volte
essere troppo avanti
non ti porterà da nessuna parte nel 2000
cosa stava accadendo in tanti quelli più
gufi quelli che speravano che nulla si
potesse evolvere
credevano nel millennium bug io credevo
in qualcosa di diverso provavo a
sperimentare nuovi contenuti
lo facevo su mezzi vecchi e su mezzi
nuovi
mi occupavo di quei messaggini che
arrivano alle persone sul cellulare
arrivavano allora dovevi mollare la
fidanzata mandavi un messaggio e ti
arrivava in cambio un messaggio per
mollarla fidanzato per fare una
dichiarazione d'amore
ecco mi occupavo di quei contenuti mi
occupavo di contenuti di informazione
per alcuni giornali e realizzava una
trasmissione radiofonica in cui le
persone si scambiavano il proprio numero
di cellulare e abbiamo realizzato più di
un matrimonio grazie a quella
trasmissione
una sorta di timber del epoca
praticamente molto prima che come dire
le applicazioni arrivassero nel nostro
mondo
ecco sperimentando tutti quei contenuti
ho imparato una seconda cosa che ci
tengo a condividere con voi oggi
pomeriggio be useful una regola
fondamentale del digitale è sì utile
cerca di capire quali sono i bisogni
delle persone i bisogni espliciti
impliciti anche latenti e cerca di
rispondere ai bisogni delle persone
nel 2005 è stato un anno importante per
me ho compiuto 30 anni finalmente uomo
fatto e finito e ho pubblicato il mio
primo libro che non è stato pubblicato e
che non era un libro nel 2005 quando
ancora il self publishing non esisteva
come termine la prima piattaforma di
questo tipo si iniziava a intravedere in
america sarebbe arrivata l'anno dopo poi
in italia si chiamava lulu beh io ho
provato a fare quella cosa senza ancora
sapere cosa fosse ho pubblicato su un
sito internet non avendo un editore a
disposizione la storia di tante persone
che provavano a capire come affrontare
questo nuovo mondo era la storia di
generazione mille euro
poi dopo tante proposte editoriale è
arrivata in libreria con rizzoli
abbiamo fatto sette edizioni straniere è
diventato un film uscito sia in italia
che in germania e ha conquistato la
prima pagina dell'international
altri bio nel quotidiano più importante
al mondo per denunciare la situazione
che c'era in italia e tutto questo è
stato possibile grazie al digitale e
allora mi porto via una terza regola b e
pioneer
segui la tua strada non ascoltare sempre
solo gli altri e cerca di essere
determinato per raggiungere i tuoi
obiettivi
e così arriviamo al 2009 era normale
guardare i video su mtv e youtube
era una cosa che quasi nessuno ancora
utilizzava tre decise di lanciare il
primo videofonino e mi chiese di
realizzare una delle prime trasmissioni
televisive al mondo pensate per il
videofonino
si chiamava italian job raccontavamo le
professioni nuove degli italiani
e lì ho imparato un'altra regola la
quarta che voglio condividere con voi i
quat ed ex padova oggi pomeriggio che b
everywhere è una regola fondamentale del
digitale dobbiamo essere ovunque
dobbiamo essere dove le persone sono
così arriviamo al 2015 avevo
perfettamente compreso l'importanza del
digitale della digital transformation
dell'open innovation a facevo il manager
facevo il consulente aveva una carriera
brillante e ho deciso di riprendere la
vita in mano e giocare nuovamente con la
vita ho mollato le sicurezze
sono entrato nel mondo di talend garden
la più grande rete di coworking europea
fondata da un ragazzo di 21 anni e con
lui abbiamo creato la tag innovation
school la prima scuola del digitale in
italia per riuscire ad accompagnare le
persone in un mondo del lavoro che c'è
che esiste e che da tante possibilità
chi è preparato per fare quelle
professioni e lo abbiamo fatto per
riuscire a trasmettere agli altri una
cosa importantissima che è trasformare
la propria passione in un lavoro abbiamo
portato in italia per la prima volta i
bootcamp master di 12 settimane per
formare da zero i junior web developer
una delle professioni oggi più richieste
dal mercato abbiamo fatto la stessa cosa
sull'e commerce sul design
abbiamo spiegato a chi fa digital
marketing che c'è un nuovo modo di farlo
con buffet king ci siamo occupati del
mondo dei dati e ci siamo dedicati anche
ai più piccoli con in generation per
insegnare a programmare i videogame ma
anche ai ragazzi piccolissimi ecco mi
porto a casa una quinta regola da questa
esperienza che be open cioè si pronto ad
ascoltare a imparare a guardare cosa
succede nel mondo e fai queste cose
molto velocemente
ecco la vita è un gioco la vita è una
continua sfida con se stessi un continuo
salto the next padova ha voluto
intitolare questa giornata
let's play ma quel l'ex play non è solo
caratteristica di tex padova è qualcosa
che ci dobbiamo portare dietro ogni
giorno che col digitale ha molto a che
fare
il digitale è la nostra vita e in
digitale possiamo affrontarlo se
riusciamo a fare le cose giuste al
momento giusto se siamo utili agli altri
se siamo di testa dura e quindi
riusciamo a essere dei pionieri se siamo
ovunque con ciò che facciamo e se siamo
aperti continuamente all'innovazione e
al cambiamento
ecco il digitale prima di tutto un
approccio non è solo e soltanto
tecnologia è un modo di fare un modo di
pensare digitale vuol dire imparare a
guardare oltre e quando si guarda oltre
che cosa si fa ci si riprende la propria
vita in mano e ser inizia a giocare
perché il gioco più bello è proprio
costruire ogni giorno con le nostre mani
le nostre forze e le nostre energie
la nostra vita